welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and squid game on netflix is a
shocking social experiment and
devilishly crafted mystery well
deserving of its meteoric popularity at
least for the way this show made me feel
all the
feels oh god
oh no
stop running
come on
i can't do this
[Music]
and i cannot believe i cried over that
man this final reveal was so well set up
with a sequence of clues throughout each
episode and while i normally apply my
breakdown skills to marvel titles i just
have to break down every interesting
clue that you might have missed in squid
game so this series follows kion and
other debtors participating in a violent
survivor challenge for cash based on
children's games red light green light
honeycomb tug of war marbles hopscotch
and the squid game their dormitory walls
actually display each of these games
from the very beginning barely visible
in episode 1 but as each stack of bunks
are removed as people are killed off all
of the games are eventually revealed now
early on gion meets ilnam an elderly
player with a brain tumor who as we
learned in the final episode was
actually the creator of the game bored
with watching alongside elite vip
gamblers who bet on these players like
the horse's kyon would bet on and so
ilnam joined the game to make the most
of his dying months and finally found a
friend in gyun he fakes his death during
the heartbreaking marbles challenge
setting up gian to win it all and it
ends with gyun debating ilnam on his
deathbed about the core morality of
society using a dying homeless man
outside as a test case for whether
anyone would stop to help him by
midnight which i actually see is pretty
similar to the final act of the dark
knight batman joker using the fairies is
a microcosm of society's selfishness or
selflessness and in the end of both
thank goodness humanity steps up now
illnone being behind it all was actually
foreshadowed in several subtle ways like
all the way back in episode one when
geon first meets him he is counting the
number of other players which he claims
was suggested by his doctors to help
with his dementia but guillain naively
points to the screen listing the total
number and illnob just looks at him like
uh
and that is because illnam was actually
sizing up each of the candidates and
he's genuinely kind of annoyed that gyan
is bothering him
now if you're currently waging battles
against puddles mud and snow in the
ongoing war against soggy socks there is
one weapon you need in your arsenal and
that is vessy shoes thanks to bessie for
sponsoring this video besties are the
perfect everyday shoe so vetsies are
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof they keep your winter
feet dry and warm without any of the
stomp stompiness of big old boots
they're made with this dimetex material
that's super easy to clean with just a
rinse of
water no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
weezies but my oinky oinkies are blown
dry like the dune sea thanks bessie
whatever this season these are truly an
everyday shoe besties should be your
go-to shoes by your door check them out
in the link below for your own pair of
bessie shoes and thanks again to vessi
for sponsoring this video my feet and my
hands have never felt cozier throughout
the games while other players are
terrified illnum is gleeful and red
light green light after the first wave
of slaughtering he happily strides
forward and when he freezes on the
motion sensor screen all other players
are lit with a full green overlay
whereas he only has a bit of green
highlighting no overlay showing how the
censor sees him differently in the
protest vote ilnom votes last voting to
end the game which he does to free
himself of guilt and ensure that
everyone who returns to play does so
under their own free will basically his
own sick justification for going forward
with this illness runs into gion outside
the store in episode two
yeah no answer to that question illna
leaves it unsaid because he doesn't want
to tell gion where the island is or even
say out loud in a public place that
there exists this battle royale island
with murder games also notice that while
we see every other major character get
gassed as they sit in the van to return
to the game we do not see any gas
clouding around illnom since he would
have known the way gassing him would
have been unnecessary now despite
ilnom's elite status he was fully
prepared to die in each of the games he
wasn't really rigging them for himself
and that's because the whole heartless
fairness of it is what made it fun for
him he was gonna die anyway because of
his tumor like in the honeycomb
challenge he straight up picked one of
the more challenging star shapes
and only by copying gyan licking the
back did he succeed it was his
friendship that he discovered with guyon
that made him want to keep moving
forward in episode 4 the nighttime brawl
only ends when ilnam cries out
and then only then does the front man
send the guards in which brings us to
the tug of war challenge and of course
ilnom knows a pretty solid strategy and
when they first pull back to tug he's
actually got a big smile on his face but
illinom was actually very close to death
here i actually checked he really was
chained to the rope like the others were
but only thanks to seongwoo's last
minute tactic to step forward and make
the other side lose their footing were
they able to win and then right
afterwards while the others look
exhausted and relieved ilnom again has a
big smile on his face now episode 5 is
when the police officer john ho finds
the player records and when he looks at
a past year there is a page for player 1
and player 2 of that year but when he
pulls the current year of 2020 the very
first page shows player 002 there is no
record for 001 since ilnam as a game
creator would not need a player record
now in episode 6 gion gives ilnom his
jacket to cover his soiled pants and
ilnam later gives him his 0-1 jacket
his way of telling kion that the guards
look up to player001 and this marks geon
for safer passage heading into the final
challenges now during the marble game
the set perfectly recreates illnob's old
home which they would only be able to do
if he had a hand in designing it and he
says
[Music]
as a way to watch people play the games
that his son played that he always
wished he played with his son and this
building looks like it has a kind of
interior giving illness plenty of places
to hide to fake his death indeed when he
loses his marbles
the guard gunshot happens behind the
pillar
and we hear the gunshot but no sound of
a body hitting the ground and on the
final shot despite everywhere else
strewn with corpses no body or blood can
be seen in the courtyard that we were
just in now as we head into the final
episodes each major character's death
was actually foreshadowed by their
decisions back in episode two like ali
stole the money from his boss and left
him with his hand disfigured just like
his own and then later in the marvel
challenge song woo steals the marbles
from him juksu jumped off the bridge to
escape his enemies and later minio
forces him into a death ball from the
glass bridge cebiak pressed a knife
against her broker's neck and she is
later killed by song woo slitting her
throat and song woo nearly committed
suicide in his bathtub and then later
kills himself to let giun win now this
all began with beyond being offered red
or blue in the train station gian chose
blue and actually later when the guards
expose all of their debts it looks like
most of the other players there also
chose blue and this might be a clue for
how the organization recruits these poor
people blue for players of the game who
they dress in turquoise red for how they
recruit the oppressive guards who are
dressed in red and you'll notice that in
the final minutes kion has dyed his hair
red and spots that recruiter again
targeting a new candidate who also chose
blue now he ends up taking that card
from the guy and calls it and the
respondent knows that he is about to
board a flight proving that they are
still watching him but he is now marked
in red and he takes on the role of the
aggressor to burn it all down i loved
this series so much it's gonna like stay
with me for a long time but if you're
new to this channel thank you so much
for watching us new rockstars breaks
down the details you missed with
in-depth analyses of everything you love
from marvel star wars to horror films so
subscribe for more content like this and
you can support us by checking out our
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign